From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
This is my detective book. I would go to the library and get all these books out on the FBI, take notes, learn words.
这是我的侦探手册。我会去图书馆，借出所有关于FBI的书，做笔记，学习专业术语。
So this book, just to describe it, it's an old, loose-leaf notebook with 1960s-era flowers all over it and stickers all over the cover.
为了描述一下这本书，它是一本旧的活页笔记本，上面印满了60年代风格的花朵，封面贴满了贴纸。
Really tacky stickers.
非常俗气的贴纸。
How many of us today have had a moment where we entertained that dream of being a private eye, of being Kojak or Columbo or Rockford or-- there are just so many. Well, I'm Ira Glass. And, of course, every week on this program we bring you a variety of stories documenting every day life in these United States. And on today's program, we're going to hear a number of stories about people who want to be detectives, adults and children.
今天我们中有多少人曾有过想当私家侦探的梦想，想成为科贾克、科伦坡、洛克福德或是——这样的人实在太多了。好吧，我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都会在这个节目中为您带来各种故事，记录美利坚合众国的日常生活。在今天的节目里，我们将听到一些关于想要成为侦探的人们的故事，无论是成年人还是孩子。
And we'll begin with one of the purest expressions of this desire you could possibly find. And that is a child's handmade detective notebook. Andrea DeFotis brought it in. And one of the things that's interesting about it-- and I think this is probably a typical problem for many armchair, wannabe detectives-- is that it records her desire to gather clues and solve cases. But sadly for her, she was leading a life where there were really not that many cases to be solved.
我们将从这一愿望最纯粹的表现形式之一开始讲起。那就是一个孩子亲手制作的侦探笔记本。安德烈亚·德福蒂斯把它带来了。有趣的是——我认为这可能是许多“沙发侦探”或想要成为侦探的人的典型问题——它记录了她收集线索和破案的渴望。但遗憾的是，她所过的人生中，并没有那么多案子可以破。
OK, here's "Mystery Update File, June 6, 1981." How old were you?
好，这是“神秘更新档案，1981年6月6日”。你当时多大？
11.
11岁。
You were 11. OK, "June 6, 1981, 4:33 PM. No new mysteries. How depressing." Next entry, "June 7, 1981, 5:34 PM. No new mysteries. June 8, 1981, 6:07 PM. No new mysteries." This goes on.
你当时11岁。好，“1981年6月6日，下午4:33。没有新谜团。真令人沮丧。”下一条，“1981年6月7日，下午5:34。没有新谜团。1981年6月8日，下午6:07。没有新谜团。”这种情况一直持续。
But I change the words to make myself feel better. "No new cases."
但我改了措辞，好让自己感觉好受点。“没有新案子。”
"No new cases." OK.
“没有新案子。”好吧。
The book is divided up into sections with names like Solved, Unsolved, though if you look inside it, you cannot tell the difference. The things inside Solved and the unsolved stuff, they're exactly the same. There's a section on how to secretly code messages. There's the record of a successful case where Andrea found her sister's necklace, a very tough case. It was on the ground, behind a bureau.
这本书被分成了几个部分，比如“已破案”、“未破案”，但如果你往里看，根本分不出区别。已破案和未破案里的内容完全一样。里面有一节讲如何秘密编码信息。还有一份成功破案的记录，安德烈亚找到了她姐姐的项链，这可是一起非常棘手的案件。它当时就在五斗橱后面的地上。
There are pamphlets on the FBI on subjects like fingerprints, a pamphlet called How You Can Help the FBI Stop Embezzlement and Fraud. There's a vocabulary section, something that many adult detectives really don't spend enough time with, I think. The vocabulary section has tough words and phrases in it like "Treasury Enforcement School."
里面还有关于FBI的小册子，主题包括指纹，还有一本叫《你如何能帮助FBI制止贪污和诈骗》的小册子。还有一个词汇表部分，我认为很多成年侦探都没有在这一块投入足够的时间。词汇表里有像“财政执法学校”这样艰深的词汇和短语。
Officially, at some point, I had a club with my friend, Tammy. And so this is the Q and A of qualifications for Tammy.
官方来说，我在某个时候和我的朋友塔米办了个俱乐部。所以这是给塔米的资格问答。
Qualifications if she could get in the club?
如果她想加入俱乐部，需要什么资格？
I guess to be sneaky, or to be a detective or part of the FBI club, something like that. The first question is "Do you know who Agatha Christie is?" Her answer was, "I have heard of her." Number two, "Do you know who Donald J. Sobol is?" Answer, "No way."
我想是为了变得鬼鬼祟祟，或者是为了成为侦探或FBI俱乐部的一员之类的。第一个问题是“你知道阿加莎·克里斯蒂是谁吗？”她的回答是，“我听说过她。”第二个，“你知道唐纳德·J·索博尔是谁吗？”回答，“根本不知道。”
I don't either.
我也不知道。
Neither do I. But I knew in 1981. But I don't know now.
我也不知道。但我1981年时知道。但现在不知道了。
Number three, "Do you think you are sneaky?" Answer is yes. Why? "Well, I sneak snacks. And spying is fun, but I'm too tall for it."
第三个，“你认为你自己鬼鬼祟祟吗？”回答是肯定的。为什么？“嗯，我偷吃零食。而且间谍活动很有趣，但我个子太高了，不适合。”
"Do you know what the four types of fingerprints are? Do you have a magnifying glass? Do you have talcum powder? Do you ever look at wanted posters? Do you ever read Alfred Hitchcock mysteries?"
“你知道四种指纹类型是什么吗？你有放大镜吗？你有滑石粉吗？你看过通缉令吗？你读过阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克的悬疑小说吗？”
And then there was scoring. And the tie-breaking question-- I guess she needed it, yeah, because she tied-- "What are the three things you should take on a mystery?"
然后还有评分。还有加时赛的问题——我想她需要这个，是的，因为她平局了——“去查案时你应该带的三样东西是什么？”
What are the three things you should take on a mystery?
去查案时你应该带的三样东西是什么？
Well, of course, Ira, it's a flashlight, a compass, and a magnifying glass.
嗯，当然了，艾拉，是手电筒、指南针和放大镜。
And at age 11, Andrea DeFotis wrote to the FBI and got an application to become a special agent. She's still got it in the notebook. It's 11 pages long.
11岁时，安德烈亚·德福蒂斯写信给FBI，申请成为一名特别探员。她至今还保留着那份申请表，有11页长。
It asks if you've ever had an alias. 11-year-old Andrea wrote, "Yes, Peanut," her nickname at the time. Employment history for the 11-year-old Andrea-- "None." "Are you interested in the fingerprint examiner position in Washington, DC?" 11-year-old Andrea says, "Yes."
上面问你是否有过别名。11岁的安德烈亚写道，“有，花生”，那是她当时的绰号。11岁的安德烈亚的工作经历——“无。”“你对华盛顿特区的指纹鉴定职位感兴趣吗？”11岁的安德烈亚说，“感兴趣。”
"Are you willing to proceed to Washington, DC, or any other duty station at your own expense?" 11-year-old Andrea says, "Yes." References-- Anne Fotzikis, turns out to be her godmother. The application asks, "Number of years acquainted?" Andrea writes, "11."
“你愿意自费前往华盛顿特区或其他值勤岗位吗？”11岁的安德烈亚说，“愿意。”证明人——安妮·福齐基斯，原来是她的教母。申请表上问，“相识年数？”安德烈亚写道，“11年。”
I thought that I would be a great FBI agent because I had 20-20 vision. And I read that that was one of the things you needed.
我以为我会成为一名出色的FBI探员，因为我有20/20的视力。我读到过那是你所需要的条件之一。
You're not allowed to have glasses.
你不允许戴眼镜。
Right. And I don't know if I still have 20-20 vision, but I did. But then I read-- I got really depressed. In fact, here it is, quotes from The Story of the Secret Service. "A man who wants to join the Secret Service must be between 23 and 30 years old, at least five feet eight, and not over six feet two in height."
对。我不知道现在我是否还有20/20的视力，但当时我有。但后来我读到——我真的很沮丧。实际上，就在这里，引用自《特勤局的故事》。“想要加入特勤局的男子必须在23岁到30岁之间，身高至少五英尺八英寸，不超过六英尺二英寸。”
Must be a man?
必须是男性？
Yeah. And then I got upset because I realized I wasn't going to probably be tall enough. But listen to this--
对。然后我很难过，因为我意识到我的个子可能不够高。但听听这个——
And you're not a man, not to put too fine a point on it.
而且你不是男性，这话虽然说得有点太直接了。
What is it about this dream of being a g-man, a detective, a spook, a sleuth, a private eye? Fill in your own-- there's so many words for this. It's like Eskimos having so many words for the word snow. Well, today on our program, the dream of being a private eye, and how that dream measures up to reality.
想当联邦调查员、侦探、间谍、私家侦探，这种梦想究竟是怎么回事？你自己填空吧——这类词实在太多了。就像爱斯基摩人有那么多形容雪的词一样。嗯，今天在我们的节目中，我们将探讨成为私家侦探的梦想，以及这个梦想在现实中是如何体现的。
Act One, Wannabes. Writer David Sedaris tells the story of two armchair detectives in his own family, and how they handle a crime wave that occurs right under their own roof, in their own home. Act Two, Real World. I go on a stakeout, me, with a real private eye, right here in Chicago, in a location so profoundly sinister that I cannot even disclose it to you on our program. Stay with us.
第一幕，梦想家。作家大卫·塞达里斯讲述了他自己家庭中两位沙发侦探的故事，以及他们是如何处理发生在自己屋檐下、在他们自己家里的一连串犯罪的。第二幕，真实世界。我要去蹲点，我自己，和一名真正的私家侦探，就在芝加哥，地点非常邪恶，我甚至不能在我们的节目中告诉你。请留在这里。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "RAYMOND CHANDLER EVENING" BY ROBYN HITCHCOCK]
[播放音乐 - 罗宾·希区柯克的《雷蒙德·钱德勒之夜》]
Act One, Wannabe. Detectives are just one of those things, like amnesia, or asteroids hitting earth, or talking animals, or seven-year-olds with the wisdom of adults, one of those things that just seems to occur a lot more in the movies then they ever do in real life. But I suppose so many things fall into that category. Why detective stories, though?
第一幕，梦想家。侦探就像失忆、陨石撞击地球、会说话的动物或拥有成年人智慧的七岁小孩一样，是那种在电影中出现的次数远多于现实生活中的东西。但我认为很多事情都属于这一类。不过，为什么偏偏是侦探故事呢？
Somebody once said-- and I would agree with this-- that every good story is a detective story, meaning every good story in any genre raises some big question at the beginning, some thing that we want to find out. And then the process of the story, the reason why we keep reading or watching is that we just want to know. We want to know what is going to happen. What is the thing? We want the answer.
曾经有人说——对此我表示赞同——每一个好故事都是侦探故事，意思是任何类型的好故事在开头都会提出一个重大问题，即我们想要查明的东西。然后故事的过程，我们持续阅读或观看的原因，就是因为我们只想知道。我们想知道会发生什么。那件事是什么？我们想要答案。
Mysteries are just the purest form of this. They offer the satisfaction of this kind of story in the purest possible way. The question couldn't be clearer. There's a crime. Who did it? And by the end, all is revealed. Light is shed. We know the answer.
悬疑故事正是这种形式最纯粹的表现。它们以最纯粹的方式提供了这种故事的满足感。问题再清楚不过了。发生了犯罪。是谁干的？到最后，一切真相大白。黑暗被驱散。我们知道了答案。
So they're hard to resist. The problem, of course, is if you see so many detective stories, if you read so many, see so many TV shows, that you start believing that you can actually do what the fictional characters in the shows are able to do. We have this story from writer David Sedaris about his own family.
所以它们让人难以抗拒。当然，问题在于，如果你看了太多的侦探故事，读了太多的书，看了太多的电视节目，你就会开始相信你真的能做到虚构角色在剧中能做的事情。我们有这篇来自作家大卫·塞达里斯关于他自己家庭的故事。
My mother had a thing for detectives, be they old, blind, or paralyzed from the waist down, she just couldn't get enough. My older sister shared her interest. Detective worship became something they practiced together, swapping plot lines the way other mothers and daughters exchanged recipes or grooming tips.
我母亲对侦探情有独钟，无论是老的、瞎的还是腰部以下瘫痪的，她都看不厌。我姐姐也和她有同样的兴趣。侦探崇拜成了她们共同练习的东西，就像其他母亲和女儿交换食谱或美容秘诀一样交换剧情。
One television program would end and the next one begin, filling our house with the constant din of gunfire and squealing tires. Downstairs, the obese detective would collect his breath on the bow of the drug lord's pleasure craft, while up in the kitchen, his elderly colleague hurled himself over a low brick wall in pursuit of the baby-faced serial killer. "How's your case coming?" my mother would shout during commercial breaks. Cupping her hands to the side of her mouth, Lisa would yell, "Tubby's still tracking down leads, but I'm betting it's the Chinesey guy with the eye patch and the ponytail."
一个电视节目结束，另一个接着开始，让我们的房子里充满了枪声和轮胎摩擦地面的嘈杂声。楼下，肥胖的侦探在毒枭游艇的船头喘息，而楼上厨房里，他年迈的同事为了追捕娃娃脸的连环杀手，奋力跃过矮砖墙。“你的案子进展如何？”广告间隙我母亲会大喊。丽莎双手围在嘴边大喊道：“胖子还在追踪线索，但我敢打赌一定是那个戴眼罩、扎马尾辫的中国人干的。”
Theirs was a world of obvious suspects. Looking for the axe murderer? Try the emotionally disturbed lumberjack loitering near the tool shed behind the victim's house. Who kidnapped the guidance counselor? Perhaps it's a 30-year-old 10th grader with a gym bag full of bloody rope.
她们的世界里充满了明显的嫌疑人。寻找斧头杀手？试着找那个在受害者家后的工具棚附近游荡的情绪不稳定的伐木工。谁绑架了心理辅导老师？也许是一个背着装满血绳子健身包的30岁十年级学生。
It was no wonder these cases were solved so quickly. Every clue was italicized with a burst of surging trumpets. And under questioning, the suspects snapped like toothpicks, buckling in less time than it took to soft boil an egg.
难怪这些案子破得那么快。每一个线索都用一连串激昂的号角声强调着。而在审讯中，嫌疑人就像牙签一样脆弱，屈服的时间比煮一颗软心蛋还要短。
"You want to know who set fire to the skate ranch? All right, it was me. You satisfied now? That's right, me. I did it, me. Give me a pair of skates and a book of matches, and I'll burn this whole town down. Do you hear me?"
“你想知道是谁放火烧了滑板牧场？好吧，是我。你现在满意了吗？没错，是我。我干的，是我。给我一副滑板和一盒火柴，我就把这整个镇子都烧了。你听见了吗？”
It's easy to solve a case where none of the suspects were capable of telling a decent lie. It seemed that anyone could solve a murder, just so long as they had a telephone, a few hours of spare time, and a wet bar. My mother had all three ingredients. The more suspects she identified over the course of a season, the more confident she became.
解决一个没有嫌疑人能编出像样谎言的案子很容易。似乎只要有电话、几个小时的空闲时间和一间吧台，任何人都能破案。我母亲这三样东西都有。她在这一季中指出的嫌疑人越多，她就越自信。
Together, she and my sister would comb the local newspaper, speculating on each reported crime. "We know that the girl was held at knifepoint on the second floor of her house," Lisa said, tapping a pencil against her forehead. "So probably, the person who robbed her was not in a wheelchair."
她和姐姐一起翻阅当地报纸，对每一桩报道的犯罪进行猜测。“我们知道那个女孩在家里二楼被刀架在脖子上，”丽莎说，用铅笔敲着额头。“所以大概，抢劫她的人不会是坐轮椅的。”
"I'd say that's a pretty safe assumption," my mother answered. "While you're at it, I think we might as well eliminate anyone confined to an iron lung. Listen, Sherlock, you're going at it all wrong. The guy broke in, held her at knifepoint, and made off with $300 in cash, right?" "And a clock radio," Lisa said. "$300 and a clock radio."
“我认为这是一个非常安全的推测，”我母亲回答。“趁你在这，我想我们不妨排除任何被限制在铁肺里的人。听着，福尔摩斯，你搞错了。那家伙闯进去，用刀架着她，抢走了300美元现金，对吧？”“还有一个台式收音机，”丽莎说。“300美元和一个台式收音机。”
"Forget the clock radio," my mother said. "The important thing is that he used a knife. All right now, what kind of a person uses a knife?" Lisa guessed that it might have been a chef. "Maybe she was at a restaurant, and the cook noticed she had a lot of money in her pocketbook."
“忘了那台收音机吧，”我母亲说。“重要的是他用了刀。好了，现在，什么样的人会用刀？”丽莎猜测可能是个厨师。“也许她在餐馆里，厨师注意到她口袋里有很多钱。”
"Right," my mother said, "because that's what cooks do, isn't it? They crawl around the dining room floor, looking through purses, while the food sits in the kitchen, cooking itself. Come on now, think. Who uses a knife to commit a crime? In a world of guns, what kind of person would use a knife? Give up? It's just two little words, drug addict. It's just that simple. A professional thief would use a gun. But even a second-hand gun costs money. A drug addict can't afford a gun. They need all their money for their dope and smack, the hard stuff. These dopers have a habit to feed every minute of every day, which means they're always on the lookout for their next mark. This was a heroin addict who followed the girl home from the bank, parked his car around the corner, broke into the house, and robbed her at knifepoint."
“对，”我母亲说，“因为厨师就是这么干的，对吧？他们在地板上爬来爬去，翻着手提包，而食物就在厨房里自己煮自己。来吧，动动脑子。谁会用刀来犯罪？在枪支的世界里，什么样的人会用刀？放弃了吗？就两个词，瘾君子。就这么简单。职业窃贼会用枪。但即使是二手的枪也要花钱。瘾君子买不起枪。他们需要所有的钱买毒品和海洛因，那些硬货。这些瘾君子每时每刻都要喂饱他们的毒瘾，这意味着他们总是盯着下一个目标。这是一个海洛因瘾君子，他从银行一路尾随那个女孩回家，把车停在拐角处，闯进屋子，用刀抢劫了她。”
"If he can't afford a gun, what's he doing with a car?" Lisa asked, "And what about the clock radio?" "Screw the damn clock radio," my mother said. "And as for the car, it was stolen. He took it last Thursday from that couple on Pamlico. You saw the report in the paper, the brand new Ford Mustang, remember? You thought it'd been stolen by gypsies. And I said we don't even have gypsies in this part of the country. I said the car had been taken by a dope addict who'd use it for a couple of burglaries before selling it to a chop shop. Bingo, there you have it."
“如果他买不起枪，他怎么会有车？”丽莎问，“还有那台收音机呢？”“去他的收音机，”我母亲说。“至于那辆车，是偷来的。他上周四从潘利科那对夫妇那儿偷的。你看到报纸上的报道了，那辆崭新的福特野马，记得吗？你还以为是吉普赛人偷的。我说我们这个地区甚至都没有吉普赛人。我说那辆车是被一个瘾君子偷的，他会用它去抢劫几次，然后再卖给非法拆车行。宾果，你这就有了答案。”
She crushed her cigarette and used the butt to trawl an X through the residue at the bottom of her blackened ashtray, her way of pronouncing that this particular case was closed. "What's next on our roster?"
她掐灭了香烟，用烟蒂在黑漆漆的烟灰缸底部划了一个X，这是她宣布这起案件告破的方式。“我们的名单上下一个是谁？”
Vandalism at 318 Poole Road, breaking and entering at the Five Points Pharmacy, a hit and run traffic accident in the parking lot of Swain Steakhouse. It was always the work of a drug addict or a former police officer, a renegade, a rogue. To hear my mother talk, you'd think the sunny, manicured streets of suburban Raleigh were crawling with heroin addicts, the needles poking through the sleeves of their tattered police uniforms.
普尔路318号的蓄意破坏行为，五点药房的入室行窃，斯温牛排馆停车场的交通肇事逃逸。这总归是瘾君子或前警察干的，叛徒，流氓。听我母亲说这些，你会以为罗利市阳光明媚、打理得整整齐齐的郊区街道上到处都是海洛因瘾君子，针头从他们破烂的警服袖子里探出来。
It embarrassed me to hear her use phrases like "copping a fix" and "pusherman." "I have to go now," she'd say to the grocery clerk. "My mother-in-law's back at the house, jonesing for her lunch." "I beg your pardon?" they'd say, "Come again?" Only on network television did people talk this way.
听到她说“买毒品”和“毒贩子”这种词让我感到尴尬。“我得走了，”她会对杂货店职员说。“我婆婆回屋了，正等着吃午饭呢。”“对不起，你说什么？”他们会说，“请再说一遍？”只有在电视网络上，人们才会这样说话。
"I call the TV," they'd say. It didn't matter what you were watching when my mother or sister laid claim to one of the televisions. You surrendered it the same way cars gave up the road at the sight of an advancing ambulance.
“我抢电视，”她们会说。不管你在看什么，当我和我母亲或姐姐对其中一台电视机提出要求时，你都得把它交出来，就像看到迎面而来的救护车时汽车会礼让道路一样。
I couldn't bear the detective shows but made it a point to regularly check in with The Fugitive. This was the story of Dr. Richard Kimble, a man on the run. Falsely accused of a crime he did not commit, we were told in the opening credits that "he changed his name and his identity." The notion of identity was illustrated by a can of shoe polish sitting on what appeared to be the scuffed surface of a motel dresser.
我忍受不了侦探节目，但坚持定期收看《亡命天涯》。这是关于理查德·金布尔医生的故事，一个在逃的人。被错误地指控犯了他没有做过的罪行，开场白告诉我们“他改了名字和身份”。关于身份的概念通过放在看似是一个磨损的汽车旅馆梳妆台上的鞋油罐展示出来。
This had me stumped for months. "What?" I asked. "Would nobody recognize him with freshly shined shoes? Did he use it to blacken his face? I don't get it." "His hair, stupid," my sister Lisa said. "He used it to dye his hair."
这让我困惑了几个月。“什么？”我问，“难道没人能认出擦得油光发亮的鞋子吗？他是用它把脸涂黑吗？我不明白。”“他的头发，笨蛋，”我姐姐丽莎说。“他用它染头发。”
Lisa liked The Fugitive because, she said, "He's easy on the eyes." The way she saw it, Dr. Kimble needed only two things, a one-armed suspect and the love of a good woman. She failed to understand that despite his brooding good looks, a man of his nature could never be happy. Unlike her nightly lineup of swinging gumshoes, the Fugitive had both a soul and a memory, and would remain a haunted man long after his wife's true killer had been brought to justice.
丽莎喜欢《亡命天涯》，因为她说，“他看起来很顺眼。”在她看来，金布尔医生只需要两样东西：一个独臂嫌疑人和一个好女人的爱。她没能理解，尽管他有忧郁英俊的外表，但他那种本质的人永远不会快乐。不像她每晚那些摇摆不定的私家侦探，亡命之徒既有灵魂也有记忆，并且在妻子真正的凶手被绳之以法很久之后，仍将是一个备受折磨的人。
Most programs discouraged you from concentrating on the hero's dark inner workings. If the girlfriend was gunned down at her makeup table, you knew there'd be another one next week to replace her, no questions asked. The Fugitive had no fancy convertible or stylish wet bar. He was cut from a different cloth, my kind of cloth, the itchy kind. Lisa wouldn't know a sensitive loner if he crawled into her lap with a fistful of daisies. And it annoyed me when she labeled The Fugitive as "my kind of show."
大多数节目让你不要去关注英雄黑暗的内心世界。如果女朋友在化妆台上被枪杀，你知道下周就会有另一个人来代替她，没问题。亡命之徒没有豪华敞篷车或时尚吧台。他是由不同材质构成的，我那种材质，那种让人发痒的材质。丽莎如果有一个敏感的独行侠坐到她腿上拿着一把雏菊，她都不会认出来。当她把《亡命天涯》称为“我那种节目”时，让我感到恼火。
It was one thing to sit in front of the television, second-guessing a third-rate detective program, but quite another to solve a real case. We were well into our summer reruns when our household was shaken by a series of very real crimes no TV detective could ever hope to crack. Someone in our family had taken to wiping their ass on the bath towels.
坐在电视机前对三流侦探节目指手画脚是一回事，而解决真正的案件则是另一回事。我们正处于夏季重播期，我们家就被一系列没有电视侦探能破解的真实罪行所震撼。我们家里有人开始在洗澡毛巾上擦屁股。
What made this exceptionally disturbing was that all of our towels were fudge-colored. You'd be drying your hair when too late, you'd notice an unmistakable odor on your hands, head, and face. If nothing else, life in the suburbs promised that one might go from day to day without finding stool samples in their hair. This sudden turn of events tested our resolve to the core, leaving us to wonder who we were and where we, as a people, had gone wrong.
最令人不安的是，我们的毛巾都是软糖色的。当你擦头发时，太晚了，你会注意到你的手、头和脸上有一种无法混淆的气味。如果说郊区生活有什么保证的话，那就是一个人可以日复一日地不用在头发里发现粪便样本。这种突如其来的事态考验了我们的决心，让我们不禁怀疑我们是谁，作为人类，我们在哪里犯了错。
Soul searching aside, it also called for plenty of hot water, gallons of shampoo, steel wool, industrial scrub brushes, and blocks of harsh, deodorizing soap. The criminal hit all three bathrooms, pausing just long enough to convince the rest of us that it was finally safe to let our guard down. I might spend 20 minutes carefully sniffing the towel, only to discover that this time, they'd used to washcloth.
暂且不提灵魂探索，这也需要大量热水、加仑的洗发水、钢丝绒、工业刷子和一块块强力的除臭肥皂。罪犯袭击了所有三间浴室，停留的时间刚好够让其他人相信终于可以放下戒备了。我可能会花20分钟仔细闻那条毛巾，结果发现这一次，他们用了洗脸巾。
"Well," my mother said, thumbing through the newspaper one Sunday morning, "the person doing this is one sick individual. That much we know for certain." "And they eat corn," Lisa said, patting her head with a T-shirt. The most recent victim, she had washed her hair so many times it now resembled the wiry, synthetic mane of a troll doll.
“好吧，”我母亲周日早上翻着报纸说，“做这件事的人是个病态的人。这一点我们是可以肯定的。”“而且他们吃玉米，”丽莎说着，用T恤拍了拍头。作为最近的一个受害者，她洗头的次数太多，现在看起来就像巨魔娃娃那凌乱的人造鬃毛。
Everyone had their theories, but no one had any hard evidence. Discounting my parents, that still left six children and my grandmother, all possible suspects. I eliminated myself. And because the towels were carefully folded, I excused my brother, who, to this day, cannot manage such a complex activity.
每个人都有自己的理论，但没人有确凿的证据。撇开我的父母，那还剩下六个孩子和我的祖母，所有人都是嫌疑人。我排除了我自己。由于毛巾被折叠得很整齐，我排除了我的哥哥，他至今都无法处理如此复杂的活动。
It must smart to use a towel for such a delicate purpose. And I watched as my family took their seats at the table, waiting for someone to cry out or flinch. But nothing came of it.
用毛巾做这种事一定很疼。我看着家人在餐桌边坐下，等着有人叫喊或畏缩。但什么都没发生。
My mother and sister had always thought themselves so wily and smart. But when pressed for a suspect, they said only that this case was beneath them. If someone were to be murdered or kidnapped, they'd rise to the occasion and finger the guilty party within an hour.
我母亲和姐姐一直认为她们非常精明和聪明。但当被要求找出一个嫌疑人时，她们只说这个案子不值得她们出手。如果有人被谋杀或绑架，她们会挺身而出，在一个小时内找出罪魁祸首。
This particular case, however, fell under the category of aggravated mischief, and was therefore unworthy of their professional attention. Whoever it was would listen to their conscience and confess sooner or later. And in the meantime, my mother would stock the linen closet with white towels. Case closed.
然而，这个特殊的案子属于严重恶作剧的范畴，因此不值得她们专业关注。无论是谁，早晚会听从自己的良心并坦白的。在此期间，我母亲会在亚麻布柜里堆满白毛巾。结案。
Later that month, someone went through my father's top drawer, stealing a knee sock packed with 112 liberty silver dollars. I knew my father's drawers as well as I knew my own. Everyone did. That was how you occupied your time when you had the house to yourself. You rifled through my father's drawers before moving on to his second hiding place in the shed.
那个月晚些时候，有人翻了我父亲的抽屉，偷走了一只塞满112枚自由银元的膝盖长袜。我对父亲的抽屉就像对自己的一样了解。每个人都知道。那是当你独自在家时打发时间的方式。你在翻遍我父亲的抽屉之后，会继续去他在棚子里的第二个藏身处。
I had seen and counted these coins many times. We all had. But who would go so far as to steal them?
我见过并数过这些硬币很多次。我们都见过。但谁会走得这么远去偷它们呢？
My father gathered us together in the dining room and listened as we each took turns denying any involvement. "Dollars come in silver? I never knew that. Does the government issue them in a knee sock, or was that your idea?"
我父亲把我们聚在餐厅里，听着我们每个人轮流否认有任何参与。“美元有银制的？我从不知道。政府是用膝盖长袜装它们的，还是你的主意？”
"OK," my father said. "all right. I understand now. Nobody took my coins. I guess they just got tired of living cooped up in that dresser and decided to roll out the door and spend themselves on candy and magazines. That's what happened, isn't it? Oh, they're probably out there as we speak, having themselves a grand old time, aren't they?"
“好吧，”我父亲说，“好了。我现在明白了。没人拿我的硬币。我想它们只是厌倦了待在那个梳妆台里，决定滚出门外，去买糖果和杂志了。事情就是这样，不是吗？噢，它们可能正待在外面，过着非常快乐的生活，不是吗？”
His voice visited its highest register, and he rubbed his hands together as if he were considering a tray of rich desserts. "Free at last. Free at last, with their whole lives ahead of them. Can't you just feel the excitement? Doesn't it make you just want to throw up your hands and scream?"
他的声音提高到了最高音调，他揉着手，好像正在考虑一盘丰盛的甜点。“终于自由了。终于自由了，余生都摆在面前。你能感受到那种兴奋吗？这难道不让你想举起双手尖叫吗？”
He lowered his voice to deliver a series of ultimatums I didn't quite catch. My mind was snagged on the thought of those jubilant silver dollars, raucous and dizzy with their first feelings of independence. I pictured them splitting into groups and traveling by night to avoid any excess attention. It might prove difficult to roll over grass and leaves, so I imagined them huddled in the carport, deciding it best to stick to the roads and sidewalks.
他压低声音发出了一连串我没完全听清的最后通牒。我的心思被那些欢快的银元勾住了，它们吵闹着、晕头转向，带着初次独立的感觉。我想象着它们分成小组，在夜间旅行以避免过多的注意。在草地和树叶上滚动可能会有困难，所以我想象它们缩在车棚里，决定最好还是待在马路和人行道上。
The thought of it made me laugh. And when I did, my father said, "You think this is funny? You're getting a chuckle out of this, are you? I'm glad you find it so amusing. Let's see how funny it is when I search your room, funny guy."
这想法让我笑了起来。当我笑的时候，我父亲说，“你觉得这很有趣？你从中得到了乐趣，是吗？我很高兴你觉得它这么好笑。让我们看看当我搜查你的房间时它还会不会这么有趣，有趣的人。”
On television, a search warrant guaranteed that your home would be trashed. And this was no different. Mine was the only clean room in the entire house. This was my shrine, my temple, and I watched in horror as my drawers were emptied and my closets brutally divorced of order.
在电视上，搜查令保证你的家会被翻个底朝天。这也不例外。我的房间是整栋房子里唯一干净的房间。这是我的圣殿，我的寺庙，我惊恐地看着我的抽屉被清空，我的衣柜被粗暴地剥夺了秩序。
While searching my desk, he came across a gold-plated mechanical pencil my father recognized as his own. It had once occupied the same drawer as his coins. And I admitted that, yes, I had taken the pencil. But I hadn't really stolen it.
在搜索我的书桌时，他发现了一支镀金的机械铅笔，我父亲认出那是他自己的。它曾经和我父亲的硬币占用同一个抽屉。我承认，是的，我拿了铅笔。但我并没有真的偷它。
There was a big difference between the two. You steal things that you covet, while you take things the original owner is incapable of appreciating. The pencil had spoken to me of its neglect, and I 'd offered to put it to good use.
两者之间有很大区别。你会偷你觊觎的东西，而你拿走的是原主人无法欣赏的东西。那支铅笔向我诉说了它的被忽视，我主动提出要把它用在好地方。
Taking is just borrowing without the formality. I'd planned on returning it once it ran out of lead. What was the big deal?
拿走只是没有礼貌的借口。我打算在铅芯用完后归还它。这有什么大不了的？
The moment my father and his pencil were reunited, I became the prime suspect, tried and convicted on circumstantial evidence. There was nothing I could say to change his mind. Falsely convicted of a crime I didn't commit, there was only one thing I could do. The shoe polish was kept in the linen closet. I chose black.
在我父亲和他的铅笔团聚的那一刻，我成了头号嫌疑人，被间接证据审判并定罪。我无法说什么来改变他的主意。因自己没做过的罪行被误判，我只有一件事可以做。鞋油放在亚麻布柜里。我选择了黑色。
The Fugitive's hair always looked perfectly natural. It blew in the breeze created by oncoming trucks as he stood beside the lonesome road, bidding farewell to a town unable to appreciate his unique gifts. My natural hair looked pretty much the same way. But once the polish dried, my hair hardened into a stiff, unified mass that covered my head like a helmet.
亡命之徒的头发看起来总是非常自然。当他站在孤独的路边，向一个无法欣赏他独特天赋的城镇告别时，他的头发在迎面而来的卡车产生的微风中飘动。我自然的头发看起来也差不多。但鞋油干透后，我的头发变硬，成了一个坚硬、统一的团块，像头盔一样覆盖在我的头上。
I went to bed and found my sheets and pillow smudged and ruined. My face and arms were bruised-looking, and everything stank with the rigid, military odor of a buffing rag. It was no wonder the Fugitive was a loner. I liked the sheen and color of my new hair, but found I needed to slick it back in order to maintain a clean forehead.
我上床睡觉，发现我的床单和枕头都被弄脏、毁坏了。我的脸和胳膊看起来青一块紫一块的，整个人都散发着抛光抹布那种僵硬、军营般的气味。难怪亡命之徒是个独行侠。我喜欢我新头发的光泽和颜色，但发现我需要把它梳得油光发亮才能保持额头的干净。
This hair of mine was bulletproof. Perhaps that's what the Fugitive saw in it. You could've pounded my head with a golf club, and I wouldn't have felt a thing. I carried my soiled sheets into the woods, knowing that from here on out, things were going to be different. I had crossed over the edge, and there was no turning back.
我的头发防弹。也许这就是亡命之徒在里面看到的。你可以用高尔夫球杆敲我的头，我也不会感觉到什么。我带着弄脏的床单走进树林，知道从现在开始，一切都将不同。我已经跨过了边缘，没有退路了。
Having changed my identity, my next step was to find the real thief and clear my name. My mother and sister were fond of saying, "The criminal always returns to the scene of the crime." This was a bit of dime store wisdom picked up from one of their television programs, but I thought it might be worth a try.
既然改变了身份，我的下一步就是找到真正的窃贼，洗清我的名声。我母亲和姐姐喜欢说，“罪犯总会回到犯罪现场。”这是她们从电视节目里学来的一点廉价商店式的智慧，但我想这可能值得一试。
It was certainly true of whoever was wiping their ass on the towels. But then again, they had no choice. The bathroom was where we kept our toilet. And even if the criminal had changed their ways, they'd still need to use the john.
对于在毛巾上擦屁股的人来说，这当然是真的。但话又说回来，他们别无选择。浴室里有我们的厕所。即使罪犯改变了习惯，他们仍然需要使用厕所。
Aside from the silver dollars, my father's drawers were home to several pocket watches, a pair of cuff links shaped like dice, tie clips, fine cigarette lighters, and a deck of playing cards picturing an assortment of confident women wearing nothing but tool belts. Figuring the thief had good reason to return for more, I undertook a stakeout. My father's closet had shuttered, louvred doors which afforded a view of the entire room.
除了银元，我父亲的抽屉里还有几块怀表、一对骰子形状的袖扣、领带夹、精致的打火机，以及一副扑克牌，上面印着各式各样的自信女性，除了工具带什么都没穿。猜想窃贼有充分的理由回来拿更多东西，我进行了蹲点。我父亲的衣柜有百叶窗门，可以俯瞰整个房间。
I took my place, waiting a full hour before my mother entered the room, shouting, "I don't give a tinker's damn what they do on Mount Olympus. In this house, you don't boil a $7 steak." My intuition told me that she was talking to my grandmother.
我就位了，等了一个整小时，我母亲走进房间，喊道：“我才不管他们在奥林匹斯山上做什么。在这个家里，你不能煮七美元的牛排。”我的直觉告诉我，她在和我祖母说话。
Slamming the door behind her, she took a seat on the edge of the unmade bed. She stared down at her bare feet and then, as if she expected them to apologize for some trouble they'd recently caused, said, "Well, what have you got to say for yourselves?"
用力关上身后的门，她在未整理的床边坐下。她盯着自己赤裸的脚，然后，好像期待它们为最近引起的一些麻烦道歉一样，说：“好吧，你们有什么要说的吗？”
She picked at her toenail for a moment before crossing the room to fetch a bottle of glossy polish from the top of the dresser. This was a new shade, the color of putty. Rather than highlighting the nails, it caused them to disappear into the surrounding flesh, creating a look both freakish and popular.
她在去梳妆台拿瓶亮光漆之前，先抠了抠自己的脚趾甲。这是一种新的色调，油灰色的。这种颜色与其说是为了衬托指甲，不如说是让它们消失在周围的皮肤里，营造出一种既怪异又流行的外观。
I'd never understood why anyone bothered painting their toenails, especially my mother, whose crusty, misshapen talons resembled the shattered, nugget-sized Fritos found huddled in the bottom of a bag. She stood before the mirror, shaking the bottle and frowning at the sight of her brittle, frosted hair, arranged into a listless style she referred to as "the devil's stomping grounds." I watched then as she rummaged through her closet, returning with a tall, plastic box secured with the sort of latches you might find on a suitcase.
我从来不明白为什么有人会费心涂脚趾甲，特别是我的母亲，她那结痂、畸形的脚爪看起来就像在袋底发现的碎裂的、坚果大小的玉米片。她站在镜子前，摇晃着瓶子，对着自己易碎的、磨砂的头发皱眉头，这些头发被梳成一种她称之为“恶魔践踏之地”的无精打采的风格。然后我看着她在衣柜里翻找，带着一个高大的、用 suitcase上那种锁扣固定的塑料盒回来。
I'd been through my father's closet thousands of times, but never my mother's. "If I have something of value, this is the last place I'd put it," she'd say. "The goddamn moths don't even want what I've got." My father's closets offered clues to his inner life.
我翻过父亲的衣柜几千次了，但从没翻过我母亲的。“如果我有贵重物品，这是我最后一个会放的地方，”她说。“该死的飞蛾甚至都不想要我的东西。”我父亲的衣柜提供了他内心生活的线索。
I enjoyed uncovering what I thought to be his secrets, but felt it best to honor my mother's privacy, not out of respect so much as fear. I didn't want any possible handcuffs or hooded leather mask interfering with the notion that this woman was first and foremost my mother.
我喜欢发现我以为是他的秘密，但觉得最好还是尊重我母亲的隐私，不是出于尊重，而是出于恐惧。我不想让任何可能的镣铐或蒙面皮质面具干扰这个女人首先是我母亲这一概念。
She carried the box to her dresser and unfastened the latches, lifting the lid to reveal a pale Styrofoam head supporting a sandy blonde wig, the hair sculpted into a series of cresting waves. This was a magnificent crown of hair, so perfect it might have been styled by God himself on one of those off days he was feeling creative, rather than vengeful.
她把盒子带到梳妆台上，解开锁扣，掀开盖子，露出了一个支撑着沙金色假发的苍白泡沫塑料头，头发被塑造成一系列浪尖的形状。这是一顶宏伟的皇冠，完美到就像是上帝本人在某个他感到创造力迸发、而不是想要报复的休息日亲手设计的。
After carefully removing the pins, my mother placed the wig upon her head and studied herself in the mirror. She nodded her head this way and that, but the curls, defying all laws of nature, held their position. I knew the feeling, except that my rigid hairstyle was by this time basically cemented to my scalp. Fumes from the shoe polish were making me nauseous, and I had begun to perspire, the inky sweat running down my forehead and staining my shirt.
小心翼翼地取下发夹后，我母亲把假发戴在头上，在镜子里审视自己。她把头左右点了几下，但卷发无视了所有自然规律，保持着原位。我知道那种感觉，除了我那僵硬的发型在那时基本上已经像水泥一样粘在我的头皮上了。鞋油的气味让我恶心，我开始出汗，墨黑的汗水顺着额头流下，弄脏了我的衬衫。
"What do you say to that, missy?" my mother asked herself. She applied a coat of lipstick and brought her face close to the mirror, cocking her had and arching her eyebrows in a series of expressions that conveyed everything from heartfelt concern to full-throttle rage. Then she stepped away from the mirror, re-introducing herself slowly, as if her reflection were a guest she were meeting for the first time.
“你怎么说，小姐？”我母亲自言自语。她涂了一层唇膏，把脸凑近镜子，歪着头，扬起眉毛，做出一系列传达了从衷心关切到全速愤怒的一切情绪的表情。然后她从镜子前退开，慢慢地重新介绍自己，就好像镜子里的映像是她第一次见到的客人。
"What do you say we paint those toenails?" she asked. "Now?" she answered. "Sure," she said. "Have a seat. It won't take but a minute. What's you're hurry? Sit down, for christ's sake. They can get along without you for half an hour. Sit."
“咱们把那些脚趾甲涂了吧？”她问。“现在吗？”她回答。“当然，”她说。“坐下来。用不了几分钟。你急什么？坐下，看在上帝的份上。他们离开你半小时也能过。坐下。”
My mother sat and opened the jar of polish. "This is a new shade we call strained chicken," she said. "All the girls are just crazy about it." I watched as she parted her toes and set to work, pausing every now and then to regard herself in the mirror.
我母亲坐下打开指甲油罐。“这是一种新色调，我们称之为‘紧张的鸡肉’，”她说。“女孩们都为它疯狂。”我看着她把脚趾分开，开始工作，并不时停下来在镜子里审视自己。
"Pretty, isn't it?" she said. "You'll probably want to wear it with a sandal. That's what I'd do, a sandal or an open-toed boot, whatever feels right for you. This is a good color for those quiet times when your weekend guests have finally passed out, and you've got the pup tent all to yourself. I'm assuming from the shape of these feet that you do a lot of hiking, am I right? No? My mistake. Ever walk over hot coals to earn yourself a little extra pocket money? I thought so. Well, you just sit back and relax. I'm not here to judge."
“漂亮吧？”她说。“你可能想穿凉鞋戴它。我会这么做的，凉鞋或露趾靴，什么感觉舒服就行。对于那些周末客人们终于昏睡过去，你独自一人拥有小帐篷的安静时刻，这是一个很好的颜色。我从这些脚的形状假设你经常徒步旅行，对吗？不？我弄错了。有没有走过热煤来赚点额外的零花钱？我就知道。好吧，你就放松一下。我不是来评判你的。”
She finished her right foot and held it out for inspection. "The good thing about this color is that it's forgiving. A little on the nail, a little on the toe, a little on the carpet, and everybody's happy."
她完成了右脚，举起来供人检查。“这种颜色的好处在于它很宽容。指甲上一点，脚趾上一点，地毯上一点，大家都高兴。”
When the left foot was finished, she tossed the polish onto her dresser and fashioned a mound out of pillows, something so high that she could lie on her back without crushing her wig. It looked uncomfortable, but she seemed used to it. Spreading out her arms and legs, she closed her eyes and reclined as best she could. The unmade bed, the clothing and empty cigarette packets littering the floor, the room resembled a crime scene.
左脚完成后，她把指甲油扔到梳妆台上，用枕头堆了一个土堆，堆得很高，这样她就可以平躺在上面而不压坏假发。这看起来很不舒服，但她似乎习惯了。张开手脚，她闭上眼睛，尽量舒适地躺下。未整理的床、丢在地上的衣服和空香烟盒，房间看起来就像一个犯罪现场。
Televised stake outs tend to condense the hours of monotonous waiting into a single moment of truth. The detective arrives just in time to overhear the ransom instructions or watch the jewel thief study blueprints to the bank. I stood for an hour with a headful of shoe polish, a fugitive, watching my chatty, harried nail stylist of a mother asleep in her wig. I waited and waited for something to reveal itself.
电视上的蹲点往往将单调的等待时间压缩成一个单一的真相时刻。侦探恰好在偷听到赎金指令或看着珠宝大盗研究银行蓝图时赶到。我头上顶着鞋油站了一个小时，像个亡命之徒，看着我那位健谈、忙碌、涂指甲油的母亲在假发里睡觉。我等啊等，等待着什么揭示出来。
After she'd and left the room, I crept downstairs and washed my hair three times, taking care to rinse the tub with Comet and destroy my soiled shirt. At the sound of my father's footsteps coming through the front door, I darted into my bedroom, slapping my face and examining the glow on the darkened window. I wanted to be apple-cheeked, fresh and innocent when he rounded up the usual suspects, gathering us together in the dining room to solve the most troubling mystery of all. Who smeared his shirts and jackets with shoe polish?
她离开房间后，我蹑手蹑脚地溜下楼，洗了三次头发，小心翼翼地用清洁剂冲洗浴缸，毁掉了我那件弄脏的衬衫。听到父亲走进前门的脚步声，我冲进卧室，拍打着自己的脸，检查着昏暗窗户上的光泽。我希望在他在餐厅里召集通常的嫌疑人，把我们聚在一起解决所有问题中最令人困扰的谜团时，我是红润的、清新的、天真的。是谁用鞋油弄脏了他的衬衫和外套？
I take my seat beside the same people who had stolen the coins and wiped themselves on the towels and say, "Did you say nail polish or shoe polish? On your suits? Today? No, sorry. I wouldn't know anything about that."
我和那些偷了硬币、在毛巾上擦屁股的人坐在一起，说：“你说的是指甲油还是鞋油？在你的西装上？今天？不，对不起。我对此一无所知。”
David Sedaris. That story, "True Detective," is in his book, Naked. His latest book is Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim.
大卫·塞达里斯。那个故事，《真正的侦探》，出自他的书《裸体》。他最新的书是《给你的家人穿上灯芯绒和牛仔布》。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "PUSHERMAN" BY CURTIS MAYFIELD]
[播放音乐 - 柯蒂斯·梅菲尔德的《毒贩子》]
Coming up, speeding through a car chase, sitting through surveillance, that all happens during two days I spent with a real private eye. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，飞速穿过汽车追逐，坐在监控室里，这一切都发生在我与一名真正的私家侦探度过的两天里。我们节目继续，稍后从国际公共电台播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. Today's program, Detectives, wannabe detectives, real detectives, and the difference between the two.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，侦探，梦想侦探，真正的侦探，以及两者之间的区别。
Act Two, The Real World. You know, a reporters isn't supposed to go out on a story with big, preconceived ideas. And so I'm just going to admit up front that when I had the chance to go out with a real life private eye, this is what I expected. I expected that contrary to what you see on TV and in the movies, real detective work was going to turn out to be mundane, dull, long hours, not terribly glamorous.
第二幕，真实世界。你知道，记者不应该带着巨大的、预设的想法去做报道。所以我先坦白，当我有机会和一名真正的私家侦探一起出去时，这就是我所期待的。我预计，与你在电视和电影中看到的相反，真正的侦探工作会变得平庸、枯燥、漫长，一点也不迷人。
And in fact, the first day I spent with detective Jonathan Rosenberg of Tower Investigations here in Chicago, I was not disappointed. When I arrived at his office, he was statementizing. That was the word he used, statementizing, meaning typing up statements from witnesses he'd interviewed. Example.
事实上，我与芝加哥塔调查公司的侦探乔纳森·罗森伯格共度的第一天，我并没有感到失望。当我到达他的办公室时，他正在做“陈述化”。这就是他用的词，陈述化，意思是把证人的证词打出来。举个例子。
"OK. So the Mazda, the black Mazda had a green light?" That was the investigator. The witness answered, "A green light, correct." Investigator, "Do you know how fast the fire engine was traveling?" Witness, "Oh god, I have no idea, but it was 40 miles or maybe more." Investigator, "OK. Do you know how fast the black vehicle was traveling?"
“好的。所以马自达，黑色马自达是绿灯？”这是调查员。证人回答，“绿灯，没错。”调查员，“你知道消防车开得有多快吗？”证人，“哦天哪，我不知道，但可能有40英里或更多。”调查员，“好的。你知道那辆黑色车辆开得有多快吗？”
Not exactly The Rockford Files. Later, we drove out to an accident scene, where Jonathan took pictures and looked for witnesses, but didn't find anybody useful, which was unsurprising, really, because the accident had happened six weeks before. Also, Jonathan went to the federal courthouse to run background checks on the computers there. Jonathan says he wasn't one of those kids who read detective books and stories about g-men and dreamed of being a private eye.
这可不是《洛克福德档案》。后来，我们开车去了一个事故现场，乔纳森拍了照片并寻找目击者，但没发现任何有用的信息，这其实并不令人惊讶，因为事故发生在六个星期前。此外，乔纳森去了联邦法院在电脑上进行背景调查。乔纳森说他小时候并不是那种读侦探书、看联邦调查员故事、梦想成为私家侦探的孩子。
I find generally, those people, one, they're totally disappointed what the profession really entails. It's a lot more work. It's a lot less exciting as it's portrayed.
我发现通常那些人，第一，他们对这个行业真正需要做什么完全失望。它涉及更多的工作。它不像被描绘的那样令人兴奋。
In fact, Jonathan got into detective work by accident. His father was a lawyer. And from the time Jonathan was 19, he'd go out for his dad, take pictures to use as evidence, track people down so they could be served legal papers. And from there, it wasn't much of a leap to a real job as a detective.
事实上，乔纳森是偶然进入侦探行业的。他父亲是律师。从19岁起，乔纳森就去为他父亲帮忙，拍照作为证据，追踪人们以便送达法律文件。从那里到成为一名真正的侦探并没有多大的跨越。
Now he's 29, dressed for work in a black T-shirt and jeans, his hair starting to thin, but just long enough to be pulled into a little ponytail. A steady supply of Newport Lights and Diet Cherry Cokes gets him through the day. And unlike the hard-boiled detectives that you see in the movies, Jonathan Rosenberg is strikingly uncynical. The main impression that you get when you meet him is a decent, level-headed guy, someone who'll talk straight with you, treat you fairly. It's an impression that comes in handy in his line of work.
现在他29岁，穿着黑色T恤和牛仔裤工作，头发开始稀疏，但刚好够扎成一根小马尾辫。充足的新港薄荷烟和健怡樱桃可乐让他度过每一天。与电影中看到的冷酷侦探不同，乔纳森·罗森伯格极其不愤世嫉俗。你见到他时的主要印象是一个正派、稳重的人，一个会和你直话直说、公平对待你的人。这种印象在他的工作领域很有用。
Day two. The first thing you have to do before you go on surveillance, Jonathan tells me, is fill up the gas tank. You don't know how far you're going to have to drive tailing people.
第二天。乔纳森告诉我，在进行监视之前，首先要做的事情就是加满油箱。你不知道跟着人跑要开多远。
About 40% of Jonathan's business is surveillance work on domestic cases, people who think their spouses are cheating on them. The rest of his work is accident investigations, tracking people down, serving them legal papers, and then various insurance and unemployment fraud cases. Today's client is a husband who's become suspicious of his wife and was willing to put up $50 an hour, plus expenses, to have her followed, 10 hours paid upfront. She's been going out a lot, with excuses that don't seem plausible.
乔纳森大约40%的业务是针对家庭案件的监视工作，即那些认为配偶欺骗自己的人。他工作的其余部分是事故调查、追踪人员、送达法律文件，以及各种保险和失业欺诈案件。今天的客户是一位丈夫，他开始怀疑自己的妻子，并愿意支付每小时50美元，外加费用，让她被跟踪，预付10个小时的费用。她周末经常出去，借口看起来不太合理。
She's out on weekends. She leaves early on weekends. She started dressing a little bit sexier, you could say, when she's going to work. That's usually a signal. Also, if they start losing weight, if they had a weight problem, or if they start working out a lot.
她在周末出去。她周末早早离开。她开始穿得更性感一些，可以说，当她要去上班时。这通常是一个信号。此外，如果她们开始减肥，如果她们有体重问题，或者她们开始锻炼很多。
Today, she's supposed to be going out after work with her girlfriends from her job. We're going to wait by the store where she works and follow her to see if that's were she goes.
今天，她下班后应该和工作中的女朋友们出去。我们要在她工作的商店旁等候，并跟随她，看看那是不是她去的地方。
This is what we're going to do. When I first get there is I'm going to look for the vehicle that the client described to me that his wife drives.
这就是我们要做的。当我第一次到达那里时，我要寻找客户描述给我的那辆他妻子驾驶的车。
Now, did he give you her picture or something? Do you know what she looks like?
那么，他给你她的照片了吗？你知道她长什么样吗？
Yes, I have a photograph here.
是的，我这有一张照片。
I have to admit here that when I saw the photo, I was completely floored. Somehow, based on a thousand detective stories, I'd assumed that these would be middle-aged people, mature people, in a marriage that had gone stale over years. But the woman in this photo was 25 years old, beamingly happy, a suburban girl on vacation in Disneyland or someplace like that. And suddenly, it hit me, looking at this picture, the human tragedy of what was about to happen. If she were cheating on her husband, and we caught her, one way or another, her life was about to turn completely upside down, starting tonight.
我必须在这里承认，当我看到那张照片时，我完全被震撼了。不知怎的，基于上千个侦探故事，我以为这些会是中年人、成熟的人，婚姻在多年中变得乏味。但这照片里的女人只有25岁，笑容灿烂，一个在迪斯尼乐园或类似地方度假的郊区女孩。突然间，看着这张照片，我感受到了即将发生的事情的人类悲剧。如果她真的在欺骗她的丈夫，而我们抓住了她，不管怎样，她的生活将彻底改变，从今晚开始。
OK, now the trick here is looking for the vehicle.
好，现在的诀窍是寻找那辆车。
We circle the store where she works. And we find her car easily enough. It's out back. But finding out where we should go turns out to be surprisingly tricky. We can't just park in the alley, because she'll see us. So we have to park at one end of the alley. But then which end?
我们在她工作的商店周围转了一圈。我们很容易就找到了她的车。就在后头。但找出我们应该去哪里却出奇地棘手。我们不能直接停在小巷里，因为她会看到我们。所以我们必须停在小巷的一端。但那一端呢？
If we choose the south end and she drives north, she could lose us. And then there's the fact that we need to see her without her noticing us. Fortunately, the client chooses that moment to call on Jonathan's cellular phone.
如果我们选择了南端，而她向北走，她可能会甩掉我们。还有我们需要在她没注意到我们的情况下看到她。幸运的是，客户选择在那一刻拨打乔纳森的移动电话。
Uh-huh? OK, so you're saying that she'll probably be heading south is her normal-- OK. All right, sir. OK. You're welcome. Bye.
嗯哼？好的，所以你是说她可能会向南走，这是她通常的——好的。好的，先生。好的。不客气。再见。
We find one position. But then a truck blocks our view. We move two more times. Who ever thought that this would be this complicated? Also, it's boring. I smoke one of Jonathan's Newport Lights simply to stay awake.
我们找到了一个位置。但后来一辆卡车挡住了我们的视线。我们又移动了两次。谁会想到这会如此复杂？而且，它很无聊。我抽了一支乔纳森的新港薄荷烟，只是为了保持清醒。
Jonathan watches in his rear view mirror for the woman. He takes notes on the case. I take notes on him. And sitting in a car like this, in a way, it's just like you've seen in those cop buddy movies. You really do start to talk about everything.
乔纳森看着后视镜里的女人。他记下了案子的笔记。我记下关于他的笔记。坐在这样的车里，从某种意义上说，就像你在那些伙伴警察电影里看到的一样。你真的会开始谈论一切。
Scarface, I didn't see Scarface. Was Scarface that good?
《疤面煞星》，我没看《疤面煞星》。《疤面煞星》真的那么好吗？
Yeah, I liked it a lot.
是的，我很喜欢它。
Wow.
哇。
I like Al Pacino a lot, that's why.
我非常喜欢阿尔·帕西诺，这就是原因。
All I heard about Scarface was it's just real violent, right? That's all I heard was it was just real violent.
关于《疤面煞星》我听到的都是它非常暴力，对吧？我听到的全部就是它只是非常暴力。
Yeah, it's real violent, but the story was really good, I thought. And the acting was excellent. I just thought it was a really well-made movie.
是的，它非常暴力，但我认为故事非常好。表演也很出色。我只是觉得这是一部制作得非常好的电影。
So you know what they call a Big Mac in France?
那么你知道他们在法国称巨无霸为什么吗？
Yes, I do.
是的，我知道。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Le Big Mac.
Le Big Mac。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The Royale with cheese is what threw me. I ordered one just to see what it was.
那个“皇室芝士汉堡”让我感到困惑。我点了一个，只是想看看它是什么。
What was it?
是什么？
It's just a quarter-pounder. I was disappointed. I thought it was something different that's not in the States.
它只是一个四分之一磅汉堡。我很失望。我以为它是那种美国没有的不同东西。
A half hour passes, and another half hour. Someone who might have been the woman comes out, smokes a cigarette, goes back in, later, comes out again, goes back in again. If this woman was having an affair, she was in no hurry to get to the affair. Or possibly, the woman who we were waiting for left long ago through the front door of the shop, which we cannot see. Anyway, finally, after all the boredom, something happens.
半小时过去了，又半小时。一个可能是那个女人的女人出来了，抽了根烟，又进去了，后来，又出来了，又进去了。如果这个女人有外遇，她一点也不急着去那个外遇。或者可能，我们要等的女人很久以前就通过商店的前门离开了，我们看不见。无论如何，终于，在所有的无聊之后，事情发生了。
OK. That's our vehicle. And it looks like it's coming this way.
好的。那是我们的车。看起来正朝这边开来。
We spin around to follow her car, and we tail her for 15 minutes. Often, we are driving directly behind her, sometimes on nearly deserted streets. And still, she does not seem to notice, which Jonathan says is typical.
我们调头去跟她的车，我们跟踪了她15分钟。通常我们直接在她后面行驶，有时在几乎空无一人的街道上。即使这样，她似乎也没有注意到，乔纳森说这是典型的。
And if this sounds incredible to you, OK, try this test. If you are hearing the sound of my voice in an automobile right now, let me ask you-- now don't look in your rear view mirror-- let me just ask you, what kind of car is behind you? And how long has it been there? No one pays attention to stuff like this.
如果这听起来让你觉得不可思议，好吧，试试这个测试。如果你现在正在车里听到我的声音，让我问你——现在别看你的后视镜——让我问你，你后面是什么车？它已经跟了多久了？没有人注意这种事情。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello? OK. Your wife has just left about 10 minutes ago. We're in pursuit right now.
喂？好的。你妻子大约10分钟前刚离开。我们现在正在追踪。
Finally, she pulls into a strip mall. She parks. We park a little down the way. Jonathan opens up a map, so we don't look so suspicious sitting there, though of course, with cameras and tape recorders, we are the most suspicious-looking car imaginable. Then he pulls out binoculars, which only helps the whole effect.
终于，她驶入了一个小型购物中心。她停车了。我们停在远处。乔纳森打开一张地图，这样我们坐在那儿看起来就不会那么可疑，尽管当然，带着相机和录音机，我们是你能想象到的最可疑的车。然后他掏出望远镜，这只会帮助增加整体效果。
And sitting there, suddenly, I realize I have no idea what is about to happen. The woman is sitting in front of a store like the same kind of store she works for. So, I think, perhaps it is possible she is going to be meeting friends who she knows from her job. On the other hand, all the women back at her job left separately in separate cars at separate times. So could they really be going out together?
坐在这里，突然，我意识到我不知道接下来会发生什么。这个女人正坐在一家类似于她工作的那种商店前面。所以，我想，也许有可能她要去见她从工作中认识的朋友。另一方面，她工作的所有女人都分开离开了，坐着不同的车，在不同的时间。所以她们真的能一起出去吗？
Why were we at this strip mall? Where were we headed next? In most jobs, you know pretty much what is going to happen when you arrive at work that morning. And it occurred to me at that moment that for Jonathan, that is simply not true.
为什么我们要在这个购物中心？接下来我们要去哪？在大多数工作中，你早上到达工作岗位时，基本上知道会发生什么。那一刻我突然想到，对乔纳森来说，这根本不是真的。
I got to tell you, you're blowing the premise for my story. I was going to come out with you. I was going to say, well, this private investigative work, you think it's really glamorous and really interesting if you see it on TV and the movies. But really, if you hang around with the guys, it's kind of boring. But now, I'm out with you, and I think I'm wrong. It is actually pretty interesting.
我得告诉你，你正在摧毁我的故事前提。我本来打算和你一起出来。我本来打算说，好吧，这种私家侦探工作，你在电视和电影里看到它，觉得它真的很迷人、很有趣。但实际上，如果你和这些人混在一起，它有点无聊。但现在，我正和你在一起，我觉得我错了。它实际上相当有趣。
It is. But when you're comparing it to Magnum, P. I. or Simon & Simon, it really doesn't compare to that kind of excitement.
确实。但当你把它和《马格南》、《西蒙与西蒙》相比时，它真的无法与之相比那种兴奋。
And at that moment, the car we're following pulls out, and we pursue. And then she does something kind of strange, actually. She pulls into an alley. And she waits.
就在那一刻，我们跟踪的车开动了，我们追踪。然后她做了一件有点奇怪的事情，实际上。她驶入了一条小巷。然后她等候着。
She went straight down the alley, right?
她直接进了小巷，对吧？
Yeah. Do you think she's trying to lose us?
是的。你认为她在试图甩掉我们吗？
Well, actually I don't know.
嗯，事实上我不知道。
We can't follow her without her noticing. So we circle the block. She backs up, then drives back into the alley. Then she circles the block.
我们不能在她没注意到我们的情况下跟踪她。所以我们在街区周围绕圈。她倒车，然后又开回了小巷。然后她绕着街区转。
And finally we solve the mystery of what she's doing. Jonathan, the trained detective, is the one who figures this out. She is not on to us. She's looking for a parking space. She gets out of the car, heads into a restaurant. It's a big, cheap, family-style restaurant.
最后，我们解决了她到底在做什么的谜团。乔纳森，那个训练有素的侦探，是那个弄明白这一点的人。她没有发现我们。她正在找停车位。她下车，走进一家餐馆。那是一家大而便宜的家庭式餐馆。
You know something, I don't think that she's having an affair. And I tell you why. It's because if you were having an affair with somebody, you would not go to this particular restaurant. It's just not romantic enough.
你知道吗，我不认为她有外遇。我告诉你原因。因为如果你和某人有外遇，你不会去这家特定的餐馆。它不够浪漫。
Right.
没错。
If you were out really for sex with somebody, and you've only got a couple hours, you're not going to go here.
如果你真的是为了和某人发生性关系，而且你只有几个小时的时间，你不会去这里。
That's true.
那是真的。
But looked at another way, maybe she is going to be meet a guy here, quickly, where no one would suspect them.
但从另一个角度看，也许她要在这里见一个男人，很快，没人会怀疑他们。
I feel like I keep just going back and forth on whether I think that she's seeing somebody. Are you doing that, too, or are you--
我觉得我一直在来回摆动，关于我是否认为她在见某人。你也在这样做吗，还是你——
Well, no. I'm just--
嗯，不。我只是——
You're neutral.
你是中立的。
I'm just trying to find out the information and report it.
我只是试着查明信息并报告它。
Yeah, I know. But from moment to moment, don't you feel like you decide, "Yes, she must be. No, no, she can't be. Yes, she must be. No, she can't be"?
是的，我知道。但从一个时刻到另一个时刻，难道你不觉得你会决定，“是的，她一定是。不，不，她不可能。是的，她一定是。不，她不可能”？
Not 'til I see it.
直到我亲眼看到。
Come on.
来吧。
See, this is the clinch. This is the clinch right now. Because we know what we're here to find out is inside there. And I know the answer's inside, so why start guessing? I could just walk inside and tell you what the answer is.
看，这是关键。这就是现在的关键。因为我们知道我们来这里要查明的事情就在里面。我知道答案在里面，所以为什么要开始猜？我可以走进去告诉你答案是什么。
And so we head into the restaurant. Jonathan leaves his cameras and his notepads in the car. I leave my tape recorder. Jonathan says we'd be too conspicuous with that stuff.
所以我们走进餐馆。乔纳森把相机和记事本留在车里。我留下了录音机。乔纳森说我们带着那些东西太显眼了。
And when we walk in, we're pretty much convinced that she is meeting girlfriends from work, just like she told her husband. So we go in. And we spot her right away in a booth with a man.
当我们走进去时，我们基本上确信她正在见工作中的女朋友们，就像她告诉她丈夫的那样。所以我们进去了。我们立刻在一个卡座里发现了她，和一个男人在一起。
The way the restaurant is laid out, we can sit at the bar with our back to the couple and then watch everything they do in this big, plate glass mirror that's behind the bar. They don't serve Cherry Diet Coke at this bar. So Jonathan orders a regular Diet Coke. And we sit there.
餐馆的布局方式，我们可以坐在吧台前，背对那对夫妇，然后通过吧台后面那个大大的板玻璃镜子看到他们所做的一切。在这个吧台他们不供应健怡樱桃可乐。所以乔纳森点了一杯普通的健怡可乐。我们坐在那里。
His cell phone rings. And it's the woman's husband. Jonathan gives him the news this way. He says, very quietly, "Apparently, your suspicions were correct." The husband gets angry, which Jonathan says is unusual. For some reason, men in this situation, when they get this news, usually cry. Women get angry, in Jonathan's experience.
他的手机响了。是那个女人的丈夫。乔纳森以这种方式告诉他这个消息。他很轻声地说，“看来，你的怀疑是正确的。”丈夫变得愤怒，乔纳森说这很罕见。由于某种原因，在这种情况下，男人得到这个消息时通常会哭。在乔纳森的经验中，女人会变得愤怒。
I watch the couple in the mirror. She's telling the guy a story, gesturing with her hands. He laughs. And I think, "You have no idea what's about to hit you."
我在镜子里看着那对夫妇。她正在给那个人讲一个故事，用手做着手势。他笑了。我想，“你根本不知道什么要打击你了。”
I watch. Someday, that woman's going to look back on this night. And she'll think, "So when I drove to the restaurant, when I was driving there, I was being followed. When we sat talking that night, we were being watched. And I didn't know."
我看着。有一天，那个女人会回想起这个夜晚。她会想，“所以当我开车去餐馆时，当我开车去那里时，我正被跟踪。当我们那天晚上坐着聊天时，我们正被监视。而我不知道。”
She'll try to picture it, put it together in her mind. Where was the detective? Where did he wait? Where did he sit? What did he see her do?
她会试着想象它，把它在脑海里拼凑起来。侦探在哪里？他在哪里等？他在哪里坐？他看到她做了什么？
In the mirror, Jonathan and I watch the woman get a call on her cellular phone. And she pulls back a little bit from the man who she's with and withdraw into herself a little bit, talks on the phone. And we wonder, is that her husband? Is he just messing with her?
在镜子里，乔纳森和我看着那个女人接到一个电话。她从身边的男人那里稍微退缩了一下，退回到了自己的世界，在电话里交谈。我们不禁好奇，那是她的丈夫吗？他只是在捉弄她吗？
She talks and hangs up. 30 seconds later, Jonathan's cell phone rings. It was him. He was messing with her.
她说了几句挂断了。30秒后，乔纳森的手机响了。是他。他在捉弄她。
He's like, "So, are you out with the girls? Uh-huh. Where are you guys. Yeah, who's there? What are you guys talking about?" "That lying bitch," he said to Jonathan. For some reason, it's hard at this moment to feel much sympathy for him.
他说，“所以，你在和女孩们一起吗？嗯哼。你们在哪？是的，谁在那？你们在谈论什么？”“那个撒谎的婊子，”他对乔纳森说。由于某种原因，这一刻很难对他产生太多的同情。
I have to tell you about the strangest thing about this entire scene. And that is that there's no sex vibe between these two people. In fact, the man is shoveling food in his mouth with a kind of circular motion of his hand that is the least sexy thing possible. It's just crude.
我必须告诉你整个场景中最奇怪的事情。那就是这两个人之间没有性氛围。事实上，那个男人正以一种手部的圆形运动把食物铲进嘴里，那是尽可能的、最不性感的事情。这只是粗鲁。
You watch him, and you think, "She is not going to bed with you, if you're going to eat like that." And in fact, when they come out of the restaurant, they go their separate ways without even a kiss, without a hug. Jonathan snaps a few pictures of them outside.
你看他，你会想，“如果你那样吃，她是不会和你上床的。”事实上，当他们从餐馆出来时，他们分道扬镳了，甚至没有一个吻，没有一个拥抱。乔纳森在外面给他们拍了几张照片。
Is that him? Yeah.
那是他吗？是的。
We follow the guy home, get his license plate numbers, get his address. It's an unusual case, because 90% of the time, Jonathan says, when somebody suspects the spouse of having an affair, the detective catches them the first time out. This case, he's not very sure what's going on. He follows the woman for five more days, over $1,000 worth of surveillance, before finally, he catches her actually going home with the guy. In the car, later, I ask him if his job ever gives him the creeps, following people around, secretly watching them in these vulnerable moments, photographing them and videotaping them, gathering evidence that will probably destroy their marriages.
我们跟踪那个男人回家，拿到他的车牌号，拿到他的住址。这是一个不寻常的案子，因为乔纳森说，90%的情况下，当有人怀疑配偶有外遇时，侦探第一次就抓到了他们。这个案子，他不太确定发生了什么。他在又跟踪了这个女人五天，花费了1000多美元的监视费用之后，终于抓到她真的和那个男人回了家。在车里，后来，我问他，这份工作是否曾经让他感到毛骨悚然，跟踪人们，秘密地在这些脆弱的时刻监视他们，拍摄和录像他们，收集可能毁掉他们婚姻的证据。
Well, that's always upsetting. You never really want to see that happen to people. But if it came to be that way, it did. It was through no fault of my own.
嗯，那总是令人不安的。你从来不真的想看到那样的事情发生在人们身上。但如果是那样的话，它就是那样。这并不是我的错。
And these people made their decision to partake in the activities they chose to partake. And if they're not being faithful to each other, then maybe they really shouldn't be married. It's that old saying. It's better to find out now than later.
这些人们做出了决定参与他们选择参与的活动。如果他们对彼此不忠，那么也许他们真的不应该结婚。这就是那句老话。现在发现总比以后发现好。
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话铃声]
Hello? I should be home about 9:30, 10 o'clock. But if I'll be home later, I'll call you. OK. Love you, too. Bye. That's the wife.
喂？我大约9:30、10点左右应该能到家。但如果我会晚点回家，我会打给你。好的。我也爱你。再见。那是妻子。
Jonathan's actually a newlywed. He's been married for only eight months. And he says, yes, having this job has affected his view of marriage.
乔纳森实际上是个新婚丈夫。他结婚才八个月。他说，是的，拥有这份工作影响了他对婚姻的看法。
How can it not? You're more careful about it, because you see it. But it really hasn't affected me in a negative way with my relationship with my wife.
怎么可能不影响呢？你对它更小心了，因为你看到了。但它并没有以负面方式影响我和我妻子的关系。
You were saying when we were inside that you guys joke about it, in fact.
你在里面的时候说你们实际上开玩笑说这件事。
Oh yeah, we do, we do. If I ask her, "What time are you going to be home?" And then she'll be like, "Well, I'm not going to tell you. I got to go meet my boyfriend." And we're like, "All right. That's all right. I'll find it out anyways. I know it anyways, you don't need to tell me." Like I have a surveillance or a tail on her at that minute anyways. But we have a really good relationship.
噢，是的，我们有，我们有。如果我问她，“你几点回家？”然后她会说，“嗯，我不会告诉你的。我得去见我的男朋友。”然后我们就说，“好吧。没关系。反正我也会发现的。反正我知道了，你不需要告诉我。”就像我那一分钟反正对她有监视或尾随一样。但我们关系真的很好。
As for me, for the next few days after the surveillance, I had this experience I have never had in my life. I was completely suspicious of everyone. At one point, I was waiting for somebody outside a McDonald's. And a guy in a black Corolla zooms in, just tears into the parking lot, tears around the curve, pulls into a space.
至于我，在监视后的几天里，我有了一种我一生中从未有过的经历。我完全怀疑每个人。有一次，我正在麦当劳外面等某人。一辆黑色的卡罗拉呼啸而来，直接冲进停车场，撕裂了弯道，开进了一个空位。
And I don't know why, I felt like, "OK. I better start taking notes." I have them, right here. "Man wore sunglasses, has crew cut. Loud music blares from car. Jumps out, beefy guy, gives me suspicious look. I give him suspicious look." And then below here, on the notes, I have his license plate number, just in case.
我不知道为什么，我感觉，“好的。我最好开始做笔记。”我记在这了。“男人戴着太阳镜，留着寸头。车里播放着大声的音乐。跳出来，健壮的家伙，给了我一个可疑的眼神。我给了他一个可疑的眼神。”然后在这下面，笔记上，我有他的车牌号，以防万一。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, Julie Snyder, Alix Spiegel, Peter Clowney, and Dolores Wilber. Our senior editor for this particular show, Paul Tough, with contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Shiow-Jiau Yung runs our website.
好的，我们今天的节目由南希·厄普代克和我本人、朱莉·斯奈德、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、彼得·克劳尼和多洛雷斯·威尔伯制作。我们这个特定节目的高级编辑是保罗·塔夫，特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。肖洁杨运营我们的网站。
Production help from Todd Bachmann, Jane Feltes, Seth Lind, and Vija Navarro. Original musical scoring for David Sedaris's story by Michael Zerang. He played that music with Fred Lonberg-Holm. Mary Gaffney recorded the music here in the WBEZ studios. Music help elsewhere in the program by Mr. John Connors and [? Terry West. ?]
托德·巴赫曼、简·费尔特斯、塞斯·林德和维加·纳瓦罗提供了制作帮助。大卫·塞达里斯故事的原创音乐配乐由迈克尔·泽朗创作。他和弗雷德·隆伯格-霍姆一起演奏了那段音乐。玛丽·加夫尼在WBEZ演播室录制了音乐。节目中其他部分的音乐帮助来自约翰·康纳斯先生和特里·韦斯特。
We are informed that Donald Sobol is the guy who wrote Encyclopedia Brown. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can get all of our weekly action-packed shows in podcast form, or you can listen to old programs online. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们被告知唐纳德·索博尔是写《百科全书布朗》的那个人。我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以以播客形式获得我们所有每周动作丰富的节目，或者你可以在线收听旧节目。本《美国生活》节目由国际公共电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia, who has something he wants to say to the Sedaris family. He's been carrying this around for years. It's just been killing him.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他有一些想对塞达里斯家族说的话。他带着这个已经好几年了。这简直快把他折磨死了。
All right, it was me. You satisfied now? That's right, me. I did it, me.
好吧，是我。你现在满意了吗？没错，是我。我干的，是我。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共电台。